it's an exciting day early trials of the
novovax vaccine in australia
show it triggers antibody levels that
are even
higher than those in patients recovering
from covid19
but it now faces a much bigger test a
study in 10
000 volunteers in the uk with the first
doses given within days
the immune responses look very promising
indeed
and that's why we need to get to this
point where we can actually see
whether in fact that translates into
protection against disease which is
after all what this is all about the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine
is also in phase 3 trials in the uk
but other prototypes are likely to be
tested here as well
as the second wave of the epidemic takes
off volunteers will be drawn from the
vaccine research registry
which now has a quarter of a million
members of the public signed up
it is an unfortunate silver lining of
increased infection is that it is good
for clinical trials because it does mean
that the participants in the trials are
more likely to get exposed to virus
so that means that we are will be
quicker
to be able to demonstrate a relative
protection of those people who've been
vaccinated
the uk has now bought vaccines from six
companies
including glaxosmithkline where the
chief scientist said patrick valance was
previously president
it's reported he has a deferred share
bonus worth around 600
000 pounds but the government says he's
not involved in procurement decisions
the vaccines though will be judged on
results
this expert warns one shouldn't expect
too much from the first generation of
jabs a vaccine that would
reduce the severity of symptoms um
is you know would have a use and in the
absence
of uh you know a wide range of available
effective therapies and then that has
its role to play
but but ultimately the reason why we
have vaccines is to stop
transmission the pandemic death toll is
expected to pass
one million within the next week a
vaccine is
urgently needed and with 10 now in late
stage
trials around the world there is at
least hope
thomas more sky news